hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong a podcast By
Rotten Tomatoes I'm your host Mark Ellis
joined as always by despite some of her
wardrobe affiliations I'm going to say
very good company the owner of three
pieces of Bad Company the great classic
rock band merch Jacqueline Coley is here
how are you I'm so good and I do love I
feel like we're in a 70s mood this is
right after we're filming this right
after the previous Last of Us episode in
which Linda Ronstadt literally sang us
through tears through tears I know we're
doing a different one but I guarantee
you this time next year we will be
talking about The Last of Us in this
exact same type of episode yeah we got
some fan favorite TV and movies to get
to the golden Tomatoes as we call them
here at Rotten Tomatoes you the fans
determined the top five movies top five
TV shows that you saw in the past
calendar year that being 2022 and when
you say it's a 70s five I think fun I
think bright I think roller skating Roxy
stryer a third of World Girls creator of
the Empire host of live at the Roxy she
goes daily on YouTube are you wearing
roller skates currently how do you know
did you know
I'm just gonna roll right out of here
do you mean my brain or my shirt I mean
both oh good good I tried to match the
brain to the shoes despite what I
witness to the parking garage this
morning very intelligent young lady just
the worst driver I'm an awful driver I'm
an awful Parker
just I don't know how to I've taken all
of the classes I went to the schools I
can't get any better this is how I
determine if you had a good parking
instructor though is if they make you
parallel parked you'd have to parallel
park yeah I had to parallel park that's
the easiest part of driving wow okay I'm
really good at math and shapes I'm
really bad at speed and and how heavy my
foot is
[Music]
uh you're better than me I pretty much
only drive here now consistently like I
don't I don't like driving in this city
I honestly have developed like I
remember that lady in the beginning of
speed who's like I can't do it it's bad
for my nerves
ah okay so you're riding the bus I mean
no I'm taking the train or the person
who lives in my house drives you know I
can give you a ride if you want I mean
no can I just give why don't we just why
don't we carpool we should cars we're at
the same place we should but I don't
want to ever be responsible for Mark's
military time because let me tell you
between this show ladies and gentlemen
this one
this one is the is the one that's on
time and everything and I am a beautiful
disaster most days so I don't want to
bring that to you early today that that
was honestly because I'm shamed by how
awful I am at driving here I just I'm
not because we started this podcast at
home and now we come into the office and
I'm just not as good as this manner it's
a little easier to it's a forward fusion
fusion excuse me excuse me
I know come on well it's not gonna be
much longer because they discontinued
that now the lease is up I got to pick
something else so there's a lot of
options on the table the lady to my
right texts me which cars to not get yes
I do that on another episode of Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong for right now I want
to get into all the golden tomatoes
because boy do we have some incredible
movies and TV shows that won the golden
tomato for 2022 but there might be some
points of contention we have I think
particularly once we get to the
television side of things yeah show us
for movies like the Oscars have sort of
ratified that these movies that the fans
voted on they're pretty well thought of
all around but with the TV shows oh boy
there's a whole lot to get into and a
whole lot that we feel like maybe should
have been on that top five all that
stuff and more coming up right now but I
do want to let you all know that fan
favorite winners of the golden tomatoes
for movies it was RR The Sensational
just pure energetic film that Roxy
stryer finally caught last night very
excited to talk to you about that 95
certified fresh on the Tomato Meter 94
on the audience score and for TV here we
go your TV series of the Year according
to the fans that voted on the golden
tomato Awards Rotten Tomatoes social is
stranger things season four
[Music]
I was trying to give you Underground
Music I know what you were doing but
when I say stranger things season four
there's only one song I'm thinking of
and it is true I forgot who I'm talking
bam
you're the only one I mean you know what
that's so smart to the point now when
Metallica does live shows on the
jumbotrons that they have they actually
play the scene from stranger things wow
the guy that played Eddie saw Metallica
they invited him backstage game of
guitar 88 certified fresh for the season
same with the audience why are you going
back to the score you know you just want
to keep telling that story
Mark's gonna get tickets to see
Metallica it's born this year I'm pretty
sure if you do will you make a tick tock
of it that's like really like I gotta
get more on the talk now that I got my
hour special coming out soon so yeah I
want to see I want to see you do old man
Tick Tock with Metallica because this is
the thing the Kate Butch song The Kate
Bush song like let me be real I liked
that song it was on my like hipster 80s
mix but it was not the thing that it was
until Tick Tock made it I have had full
relationships with Tick Tock videos that
have that underneath it it's amazing I'm
just gonna Push by him calling it The
talk or were you okay with that we're
just gonna accept it on the talk I am I
am entering my I'm entering my rich
Auntie phase I am trying to bring him
into his like Uncle Vibes phase and he
was just like trying to drag against it
but I'm trying to bring him into it I'll
get there I'll get there eventually with
help from folks like you and I know Roxy
very prolific on The Tick Tock yeah you
good you just changed your ways
it's great an amazing Tick Tock presence
I love when you all do like trivia
against each other so here's my question
for you all right don't worry it's not
trivia I know how much you hate trivia I
really do I clam out my hands are
sweating I'm just simply gonna ask you
about the two highlights here on the
golden Tomatoes first movies are we all
in agreement that RR I have no problem
with that Tomato Meter whatsoever 95
certified French maybe it's a little low
no no I would even say it's it's a
little bit low this movie is a
phenomenon you saw it on Netflix did you
see it on Netflix as well yeah okay so
I've seen it on a screener which is even
worse than seeing it on Netflix but
apparently and I do know this from the
videos it is one of the most Electric
live viewing experiences that you can
ever go to and to the publicist of RR I
know you might see this I'm sorry I've
tried to see this movie live five times
and every time I've tried to see it I've
failed because it's sort of like going
to Rocky Horror Picture Show like people
dance at certain sections now I'm just
I'm so like I love that this movie won
but I just I want to see it live you're
very busy during this time of year and
we all pour one out for Jacqueline and
all the cool things that she missed out
whatever she was doing other cool things
Roxy you just saw this movie last night
95 sound about right yeah I'm an
uncultured swine so I watched it with
dubs not subs and I just want to throw
that out there because I know that
that's not cool but I couldn't there was
so much going on that I couldn't keep up
if I just had Subs on the whole time so
I'm putting that out there judge me if
you guys want other than that I think I
had a great viewing experience no it
wasn't live but I did dance along so it
kind of made a live experience for me
this was so good everybody kept saying
it was gonna be good uh joke's on me
because I thought there were gonna be
pirates in it legitimately glad that RR
was like I mean there's a lot of ours
for there to not be Pirates
you're gonna put three in the title like
that I'm expecting at least a Captain
Crunch appearance somebody who's dressed
like a pirate oh wow
I was like ah and then we started and I
thought maybe a pirate is gonna fight a
tiger that's not what happened but it
was way better than that it was just
like my soap opera but great
performances musical theater loving soul
mixed with the action-packed just
goodness all around I was kind of
expecting to dislike this movie because
it was so hyped I think that this is
like a hundred percent on the Tomato
Meter for me I give that review of RR
100 going in expecting maybe something a
little different but you got way more
than you bargained for and you were
dancing in your place well also the fact
that are you a pirate person kinda like
the fact that that did not just kill
your disappointment right there because
like I can think of a couple of subjects
does that have subtext to it when you
ask her if she's a pirate person is that
just like I like pirate movies or are we
getting to a deeper layer here I mean
that just depends on Roxy I was going
for the plain pirate but I assume that
if anybody likes something fairly deeply
that could can go a lot of ways I will
neither confirm nor deny
we need to get her on one of our after
hours
for the pirate Fascination I mean
honestly that's what our after hours
show should be just tell us your movie
King I would definitely be here for that
anybody who says that pirates aren't hot
is a liar though come on anyway
to your point though the Tigers on it
with it I'm glad that you weren't
disappointed by it what was your
favorite sort of moment from it or when
was the first moment when you're like oh
not only is this good but I'm like
digging this because this movie kind of
comes at you in waves yeah it definitely
does honestly the first 40 minutes I was
sitting there kind of like am I gonna
not like this movie What's Happening
Here once we get to not to not do it's
like game over you know like you you
just it's essentially a dance battle and
you're just watching it like oh my God
you guys are wiping the floor with them
it's just so so good and then from there
it's like nonsense yeah and it's just
fun and it's vibrant and like I sort of
had the same thing with everything
everywhere all at once didn't take me 40
minutes but like with it 15 minutes in
I'm like am I am I locked into this and
then you you just get once you make that
transition over and you just surrender
yourself to the movie I think RR and
everything everywhere all at once kind
of on the same wavelength with that
let's quickly hit on Stranger Things
four before we turn it over to our buddy
Tim Ryan Roxy stryer 88 for stranger
things four you watch more TV than
anyone who not only did I currently know
that I've ever met or ever heard of in
my entire life
stranger things season four I'm so
single and alone every time you say it
out loud stranger things season four is
super she doesn't have the right pirate
someday you'll meet your Captain Jack
sneaking my DMs
we need to get like I'm sorry Brian you
need to put a timer on the like video of
every time we say R in this one because
it's coming it's coming I could feel it
already I think stranger things is an
excellent show I think that this show is
known as an excellent it's not an
underrated show by any means everybody
watches it is like the show is Bomb was
it the greatest show of the year it
didn't make my top ten so an 88 I
actually think is fairly accurate it
might be a little high for it and I
don't want to sound like a hater because
I do love this show but I don't I don't
think that it's it's the the aces of
shows Jaclyn I like it at 88 just
because it sort of got the sour taste of
season three out of my mouth I was
pretty bored with season two and season
three it didn't really feel like much of
a rebound this one felt at least more
like classic stranger things am I done
with being in Hawkins probably yeah if
I'm one of those kids I'm probably like
hey Mom Dad we should move I mean weird
stuff that happens here a lot I just
want to go to school yeah yeah yeah
um I agree with you also I will say this
I want to just add this one little bit
about stranger things I I appreciate the
communal watching Port part of like
stranger things like I was a kid that
grew up with like must-see TV and like
Thursday night and you come on Friday
and you all are talking about for us it
was Martin and Fresh Prince for other
people it was friends and I don't know
what the other show around that was but
you know what I'm saying it was friends
with Seinfeld on NBC I'm like yeah you
don't need to tell me the the Knights of
TV were segregated kids
um but they were they were the facts I
didn't make the programming I just
watched but the stranger things has that
you can really have this sort of like
like I was saying with you you know the
songs you know the cues you know the the
things that everyone's making the memes
out of now and like look I heard the
song Chrissy wake up before I watched it
in the show does that mean it's like a
different experience yes because you
know what is happening and you know it's
coming as soon as you know Chrissy and
like what her and Eddie are you know
there's gonna to be a thing but I love
that so I actually like I'll give it
bonus points for that which I think
everyone who voted on here was that
being said it doesn't crack my top 20.
yeah well once we get into what the top
five of the golden Tomatoes awards were
four movies and TV I think that's where
there's going to be a lot of Spirited
debate maybe not necessarily between the
three of us here at the table but us
talking to you fans so yeah you're the
voters and by the way you go to
rottentomatoes.com for the entire list
check out all the golden tomato Awards
there's some achievement awards that
have been awarded to individual folks
too so a lot of good stuff I know
Michelle yo on that list
came to Brunson a few others you want to
get my editorial Spiel so we have our
Rotten Tomatoes golden tomato Awards
which was our annual Awards where we
curate the best movies and television
with a statistical fraction because this
is based on reviews in our adjusted
weighted score some of the winners this
year were Quincy Bronson as well as
Abbott Elementary some individual honors
also went to Colin Farrell and Jenna
Ortega that was it is it Jenny or Jenna
Jenna Jenna that's all right yeah so
Jenna Ortega she won for Wednesday for
Golden year these are the people that
had an incredible Year all the way
through you know Colin doing Batman
everything everywhere all at once sorry
Batman after Yang as well as the band
season mayor Sharon pretty good year you
know I spent the first 15 minutes of
this episode trying to get employee of
the month she just stole it right from
under my feet within 30 seconds with
that brilliant eloquent not even
rehearsed it was just losing her break I
was looking like are you is this
teleprompted right now are you coming
she's just that good just in the brain
they shock us
and make us say it and say
about these movies
Tim Reiner expert review curation
manager here at Rotten Tomatoes he's
going to tell us what the critics were
saying about these fine shows and movies
at the time of their release which was
if you're keeping score at home 2022
take it away Tim
moments with him all right let's get
right into it your fan favorite golden
tomato Award winners are rrr and
stranger things season four let's start
with what the critics had to say about
rrr it's certified fresh at 95 on the
Tomato Meter with 94 reviews and it has
a 94 audience score so what did the
critics have to say in a fresh review
davesh Sharma of filmfare wrote the film
runs squarely on the shoulders of its
two leads and they've given their best
to it it's as close as you get to a
Marvel film in terms of sheer visual
Delight however in a rotten reviews have
all Chatterjee of NDTV wrote that RR
Rings Hollow because it never pauses for
breath and does not Grant its two male
protagonists anything akin to
recognizable human qualities the Rotten
Tomatoes critics consensus reads
intoxicatingly over the top RR pulls out
all the stops to make the absolute most
of its 187 minute run time
now onto stranger things season four
it's certified fresh at 88 percent with
191 reviews and it has an 88 audience
score and just as a side note we covered
the first three seasons of stranger
things in an earlier episode of the
podcast so check that one out as well
but what did the critics have to say
about season four in a fresh review
Janine T Abraham of black girl nerds
wrote stranger things 4 is a
binge-worthy blast from the past that is
surprisingly relevant to our present
reality
however in a rotten review I don't step
in well over Rolling Stone wrote the
whole experience felt like being forced
to eat every menu item from the
Cheesecake Factory over the course of a
day lots of deliciousness some things
you never wanted and the whole
experience leaving you feeling nothing
but bloated the Rotten Tomatoes critic
consensus reads darker and denser than
its predecessors stranger things fourth
chapter sets the stage for the show's
final season and typically binge-worthy
fashion
so those are your fan favorite golden
tomato Award winners back to you folks
oh boy what a conversation we just had I
mean honestly like I appreciate you Tim
thank you we do we were listening to you
Tim but there was other things until
the incredible restaurant Cheesecake
Factory hit the airwave okay just
quickly favorite item
item Cheesecake Factory for the rest of
your days what are you taking
the bread that's your item is there the
free thing I've I feel very strongly
about the Cheesecake Factory bread yeah
you get the ride the ride yeah that is
the only bread that is they're not
putting the other one in grocery stores
y'all notice that right they're not
bagging up the crappy like white bread
that they put in Cheesecake Factory and
selling that at grocery stores it's only
the right yeah she goes Rye even though
we would have given it to her for free
with another dish I don't care that's
the only if I went to Cheesecake Factory
I would not be disappointed if I didn't
walk out with anything except for the
bread like I literally that's the
interesting thing about this restaurant
nobody's picking cheesecake unless Roxy
is absolutely not you know I don't eat
cheese I'm not a big cheesecake guy
sliders their sliders are bombs yeah so
good great proportions of bread to meat
also their pot stickers I know I just
cheated I'm really sorry yeah I am going
with the white bean chicken chili oh you
and the person who lives in my house are
similar he goes for the shepherd's pie
hey tell that person that lives in your
house I said hey I will I just
evaporated both of your picks I want you
to know that neither of you guys did a
good job I mean I picked bread so like
the bar was hell
pretty low for you if I had to pick an
entree okay I will make it an even
similar lame option the Chinese chopped
chicken salad which is neither Chinese
nor really even good chopped chicken but
I like the sauce it's the dressing is
delicious dressing's good too much
lettuce not enough meat for me and with
that we transition into movie slash TV
talk
[Music]
but feel free to Pepper in your
restaurant picks at any time should
another one come up like in a show
called The Bear we're not there yet
where we are we are is I'm about to
reveal the top five TV shows and movies
according to the fans that vote in the
golden Tomatoes before I get there Roxy
I just have like a blanket question for
you 2022 wise what was your favorite
movie let's start there favorite movie
they came out in 2022. Marcel the
shallow shoes on yeah some people tell
me my head's stupid for my body and I
just look at them and say
to what oh that was good right that was
amazing that's very good Awful at
impression much better than your Yoda
yeah I'm so bad that I care so much
about that movie that I've been looking
in the mirror every day like really
trying yeah yeah I'm like I think that's
what it is like these people that bust
out these Impressions that's hours of
them like working on that you know
as I know oh I know it too that's why I
don't do them on stage there's like two
Impressions I can get away with and
that's it yeah
Fiona coming out in the special so okay
gotta wait a couple months for that for
the fan favorite movies here they are as
revealed by the golden Tomatoes your top
five number one as we talked about RR
sadly no Pirates number two sort of air
Pirates top gun Maverick number three
everything everywhere all at once it's
like I'm reading the Oscar nominations
for Best Picture number four the Batman
and number five Avatar the way of water
so the Batman the only one left off the
Oscar's best picture nomination list I
believe
then our RR yeah
okay best foreign film but I I heard
that they didn't put it up for
consideration I'm not sure no it wasn't
the selection from India so the politics
about selecting best foreign film or
English not in second language is a lot
but basically every individual Nation
usually has a film board that makes
decisions and those decisions might not
be the most popular film like for
example there have been popular films
that like a portrait of a lady on fire
which is a film that everyone knows was
not Francis selection the year that it
it um got nominated for some things and
it was because of the the language it
was not in Hindu originally so they
didn't want to put it up for their
number one nomination or something like
that yeah I don't I don't know the
politics the words aren't everything
Citizen Kane lost to how green was my
valley I mean you know I mean still a
little more viewed than how green was my
valley since then so pirate would know
how green the valley was I already would
those are your they don't make it to
them
so I just gave you the top five again RR
top gun Maverick everything everywhere
the Batman Avatar the way of water Roxy
you got a big bone to pick with any of
these films do you think the fans maybe
missed one what would you put in instead
I think that the fans did a good job on
this one I'm mostly saying that because
I'm about to destroy them when we get to
television so I want them to feel good
about themselves right now wow talk
about the placation
all of these are really good I liked
every single one of these movies they
don't have Marcel in there so I can't
trust them holy and fully but these are
these are some pretty good and different
picks top gun is just like absolute
genius to me so that's your number one
pick right yes it is so the Mark's
number one is on this this list okay
just for the football seat alone
I loved that movie so much it's just
gold to me so I think that they did a
good job and yeah having everything
everywhere all at once at least we got
an a24 movie in there I'm a huge Batman
girl myself Avatar if you're gonna take
10 years to make a movie it should
probably be on a list like this and I
just said how much I love RR so they did
a decent job yeah I mean I I obviously
have top gun Maverick and I feel like
everything everywhere all at once were
my two favorites of the Year pretty much
so that I feel good about this list I
understand the Batman with the pedigree
of Gotham City and everybody loves a new
iteration of Batman and I thought it was
a real left turn for DC I don't know
where it's going from here there's even
today we might get some insight into
what exactly the future of DC films
holds but I feel like this was a solid
starting point for a Batman that could
go in a number of different directions
but I'm also excited about where the
Catwoman character goes from that film
as well so I think there's a lot of
portals that we opened with Avatar are I
really enjoyed it I think it was an
amazing theatrical experience I saw it
twice didn't have to pee the second time
who's got a strong bladder this guy
right before like a forged in Iron this
bladder no I did not have a bedpan I
stayed there and I felt good about it
the movie itself I feel like was great I
actually feel like storytelling wives
was a step up from the first Avatar film
I'm not sure that I would put it in my
top five above even something like
Marcel the show with Shoes On which I
just love a good Underdog Story both the
movie itself and the characters so I
have a little beef with the top five but
I'm not necessarily sending it back to
the kitchen Jaclyn Coley how are we
feeling I was looking to see if my top
five matched with this at all and the
only one on my top five that's in here
is everything everywhere all at once
okay yeah I think that's the only one of
my top five I was trying to remember top
top gun is not in my top five that being
said I don't disagree with anything on
this list for fan favorite movies I'd
have a hard time if I wanted to judge
these as the best movies of the year
like I would like to me there's like a
whole bunch of other films that we're
not maybe on this list that I think are
really great that also have huge sort of
like fans behind them I would put Marcel
the show with shoes on as one of those I
would also put a film like Elvis in one
of those I'm not even talking about like
we're not saying the guitar I'm saying
there's other films that have like huge
fandoms and maybe their fandoms aren't
as passionate because one thing I will
say is the nation of India based on my
mentions
um and just covering any nollie sorry
any Kali or Bollywood films or any
basically anything from India that is
filmed on television if I cover it my
mentions go insane so I know that fans
of this film really made this happen and
so that's why I'm like this is the
perfect thing for a fan favorite film
because it's a movie that feels like
audiences where the only thing that they
cared about more than anything else and
they also managed to make incredible
Cinema okay I've one hot take that I
took because I looked at my list for my
best movies of 2022 and so as we look at
the top five here we start out with
three like Tomato Meter certified fresh
99 percent and above they're they're
getting into an Ivy League school and
that's everything everywhere top gun
Maverick and RR right then you have the
Batman which is 85 percent solid Avatar
the way water 77
I am going to take the Batman out
um I'm setting a lot of people that love
commenting but in its place I'm putting
in another movie that has Blockbuster
franchise pedigree that had a Resurgence
in a different form that we thought and
that would be prey the movie it sort of
acts like a centuries-long prequel to
Predator from 1987 and I thought it was
so well done I had no idea this thing
was happening and then it just landed on
my TV it was awesome it is interesting
that there's no horror movies in the
fans barbarian's another one yeah yeah
for me the black phone oh yeah that
movie really got me screaming really
really good a movie that I would
definitely put on here also is the Fable
wins but I understand kind of based on
what you were just describing it's it's
not really like a fan favorite yeah I
just thought the movie was really good
this does speak to the fans oh can I can
I can I be I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
do this come in I'm gonna do it you get
to close this out with one more slice of
fruit no but just with the Fable men's I
luckily I'm a member of this stupid
critics Group which is silly on all
things but I got to sit with the Fable
men's for a table and I'm gonna tell you
why though is because they killed me
they put me near Seth Rogen and I
literally I was like I'm not gonna lie
to you I probably elbowed half of the
Jewish people in the credit score so I
was like I want to talk to Seth Rogan
because I just think he's the coolest in
that movie and I just really wanted to
talk to him but I I literally I was
thinking about that the other day I was
like man next it's one of those ones
where like if you get invited to Black
Panther you need a boom black person
next thing I do for the Fable men's I
think like I need to bring you I am so
happy to be your residential it's like
the best way possible like I would hope
that I would be the resident token
person that somebody would bring if they
got invited to Black Panther certain bit
like I would do that for you and I
should have done that for you
this makes me feel even better about the
amount of times Jaclyn's asked me to be
her possible that's very true
you're not you know representation that
you were bringing remarks just because I
like you Caucasian and together it makes
just this WOW adorable white guy that's
just gonna be in the corner by himself
drinking beer he's not not hurting
anybody yeah but with the rye bread so
that does give you a little spice I'm
the white bread baby and the white bread
that Cheesecake Factory does not bother
putting in grocery stores
nobody behind this off the shelf at your
local grocer but my point to say that
too though is I the best thing about the
fat woman's is how many people who have
spoken to me about how in a lot of ways
it felt like black people when they were
watching black panther like it felt like
their families it felt like
representation that they really couldn't
touch in that way like intimately unless
you were reading like some old school
Neil Simon stuff for sure when I watched
it I was like oh my God this is so
Jewish and it was really exciting for me
and I I watched it with somebody who was
not Jewish and he was parts of it he was
a little confused and I was like that's
cause enough
it's kind of anyways my whole point
being is that this experience in that
way it's it's always fun to see it
through that eyes him and Adam Sandler
I'm your plus one next time I I will be
on this I will be on this if there's a
party for Hustle
the line starts right now
in my top ten so good that I do feel
like could have like had that fan
favorite charm to get it maybe not to a
top five with the golden Tomatoes but in
contention so in Adam Sandler another
wonderful job I just I thought that
movie was such a great depiction of both
what a basketball coach goes through
yeah and also what a stand-up comic goes
through on the road it's great because
he's in all these exotic countries and
he's just cranking the McDonald's and
anything that feels like home because
he's got a flight in three hours we are
flying to the TV section here because
Roxy stryer could have a couple scalding
hot takes for us here are your top five
TV series of 2022. according to the fans
that voted in the golden Tomatoes number
one is stranger things season fours we
already pointed out number two interview
with the vampires inaugural season
number three the first season of
Wednesday number four the final season
of Better Call Saul and at number five
it was the kickoff of the Game of
Thrones prequel House of the Dragon
while Roxy's warming up in the bullpen
Jacqueline Coley how do you feel about
this list man the best thing I can say
is I love what you're starting with the
best thing I could say is they're a
passionate fandoms on television
and they showed up for this
um also look I'm gonna I'm gonna do this
before she tears the list to shreds
because I think no one is gonna disagree
with the last season of Better Call Saul
nobody is going to disagree with that
because
Prestige television we have not gone in
this hard on stranger things so I'm
gonna assume that the Venom is gonna
rest in these other three in varying
degrees but the one thing I will say
about Interview with the Vampire because
not everybody loved that show and I can
hear their points of view
but for the thirsty girls and guys out
there that movie was representation that
we need on television that was The
thirstiest Toxic love affair it is
finally Louie and and just that entire
dynamic between Louis and Lestat and
Claudia just finally done like the bad
couple that decides to have a baby to
save their relationship every bit of
that I loved for it there were not
enough Pirates
yeah it's like the 1800 I guess this
one's a little more modernized yes it's
modernized by the vampire with Tom
Cruise flashbacks we could have stuck a
pirate in there somewhere hey look I'm
all for pirates and that's really the
only chance you get other than House of
the Dragon which has some seafaring
action from time to time they start in
New Orleans oh and an eye patch too yeah
that well that's an hassle you you take
whatever you can get I guess with this
list because it certainly didn't please
me and some of my favorite shows of the
year but I will defer to Roxy's where do
you find the most ire with this top five
so I'm so sorry that everybody at home I
think you guys did a trash job on this
I don't stand with you there are some
things I do stand with uh you can't
knock Better Call Saul you can't knock
Wednesday you I don't even knock House
of the Dragon I think it's great but for
severance to not be on this list is
egregious and the other thing that I
think is like the greatest TV we've
gotten since the rye bread not the white
bread at Cheesecake Factory is the
rehearsal that you would think that
would be like a fan favorite show that
show is so up the fans alley it is so
unbelievably cringe Ozark had an
unbelievable final season
uh really surprising to me there was
just such great shows I feel like these
were the most popular shows so it does
make sense that people like this but it
is interesting to me all the time
because I I did watch I think 120 shows
last year that came out in 2022 and the
way that people talk about some of these
shows I'm like I feel so pretentious and
annoying but I'm like did you watch
anything else on TV that wasn't popular
because like Rami the greatest nobody I
don't know people who are watching it
Atlanta not being on this list again
final season not only did it have a
final season it had two seasons this
last year so there's just so many other
shows Abbott Elementary I think that
that show deserves every single flower
on the planet this this list is just a
little lackluster to me yeah and it does
feel like again you talk about the
fandoms if you don't think Interview
with a Vampire has its own fandom have
you seen Vampire shows and the Legion of
fans have you seen Twilight still like
all the people just grew up loving
vampires in the modern world and then
you have Wednesday which is sort of like
that that goth spin but also there's a
lot of humor in Wednesday I think
there's much more Nostalgia for those
early 90s Adams Family movies even more
than the TV show from the 60s that
people still tap into and so I
understand why all of these show shows
are on the list but there's a reason why
the bear is a hundred percent on the
Tomato Meter I thought that show was
phenomenal and the best episode of TV I
saw was one of the last episodes of
Atlanta where they're spoofing basically
Disney yeah and it was brilliant like I
couldn't believe how brilliant it was
and it just kept getting smarter and
funnier and so I would suffer both of
those as well which show would you take
out and which show do you most want to
put in here Jacqueline
a lot I take out sorry I was not as big
on Wednesday as other people I thought
it had Vibes I thought it was cool but
it was not my story uh Better Call Saul
I will fully admit I've never started
that show so I've watched Breaking Bad
all the way through but I never watched
better calls I was I was like you for a
while where I was reluctant like I saw
the first couple episodes and I was like
yeah this is legit great and it's like
living up to the legacy of Breaking Bad
and they just kind of fell off the train
get back in there mine back in there
this is the thing with mine is I watch
Breaking Bad I started the first season
when they were doing the last because I
don't have the patience for that kind of
show like that like it just it drives me
a little bit insane or I didn't at the
time I've developed this patient anyway
my whole point being is I waited I want
to wait till it's over now and I'll
watch it all the way through I would
definitely take off Wednesday I would
definitely take off House of dragon also
at the best thing that came out of that
show is Again The Tick Tock about
spagliato
um I think it's coming I think the show
will be better maybe in its second
season but it wasn't there I would add
Severance I think Atlanta is absolutely
another show
um also like I'm just gonna say it again
The Last of Us it's it's I know it's not
in the same timeline and so therefore
it's in this year but I'm gonna tell you
this right now this show in three
episodes has been better than anything I
have seen in probably the past three
years it is so good so good I'm super
with you yeah it's just blowing me away
yeah like I wish I could talk about
another TV show right now because
literally all I want to do is talk about
the last one yeah it's really really
excellent if that was a 2022 show for
sure it would be on here yeah it
wouldn't be online but everyone like the
bear Severance all the things that we're
saying when I look at this it's just
like I get why these might be more
popular those show the shows we're
talking about are a little harder to
consume they're a little harder to watch
even though the bear is being nominated
for comedy left and right which is
hysterical within itself that's a tough
show to fit into one box because they're
really people in my life that like I was
because I was raving about the show to
everyone right and I was looking for the
best Italian beef sandwich in Southern
California I found a few really good
ones really yeah yeah okay right in
Louie's down it's right next to the
Hermosa Beach uh Comedy and Magic Club
it's a pizza place but they have this
Italian beef sandwich that I they feed
you Hermosa comedy magic club best
comedy club food I've ever had I still
pick up the Italian beef sandwich wow
right next door tip oh it's good stuff
yeah all right so but when you recommend
the beard if you have to be careful you
have to know what they've been through
in their lives because like I'm raving
about this and I'm like oh yeah uh
there's some really heavy stuff in there
too yeah it's not all just funny Richie
you know but I just feel like everything
that show did another show that I was
surprised to see not on this list in the
top five was season three of the boys
because I feel like that has we're
talking about fandoms I feel like a lot
of folks even if they're not
understanding everything that the boys
is doing
it's so good and this season just kept
one-upping itself from the previous
episode so every season of the boys I'm
like I cannot wait for the next for the
next episode for the next season to hit
I'm curious about this with the boys
because the boys was always a big satire
in like storm troop Starship Troopers
level subversion of like you know
corporatism and all of that kind of
stuff I feel they went heavier this past
season than they have in other years and
I think it was something where it's like
oh we lured you in by just thinking this
was all rad and like you know whatever
it is and now they've gotten heavier
it's harder maybe for the fandom to just
be a bashedly like this is kick-ass I
don't know you know what I mean like it
got more serious this time yeah but
where are you on Berry because I know
you have affinity for the star of Barry
where how is season three compared to
the first two for you so this is the
thing I would say about Barry it's hard
you should have picked an easier show I
can't watch Barry with that kind of
object like where is this going is this
good or this bad because any show where
Bill Hader is writing directing and
starring is a meal that I will eat under
any circumstance and enjoy right I
follow you on Twitter so yeah like
there's no there's no there's
no like would I say that season three
was the best this last season sorry was
the best version of that show no of
course not however I know that I can see
the seeds that he is planting to wrap
this show up in probably a five or six
season Arc that is setting up for a like
it's setting up for a Walter White level
like this is gonna be a very complete
story of this character and you're gonna
feel satisfied by the end of it and so
I'm more excited about that and I'm less
interested in like oh was this season my
favorite season because I know these are
middle Innings I love Barry I'm with you
completely but it has lost all comedy
Vibes like it's just not a comedy
anymore I can't watch it and laugh
you're watching it like actually
cringing and crying under the covers
yeah probably the craziest part about
these these picks though as we were
talking a little bit more I'm thinking
about the fact that there's no Star Wars
show on here DC show on here no Marvel
show on it please talk about fandoms
yeah not even the boys so we're really
missing the superhero Star Wars that
entire thing the closest thing probably
being House of the Dragon I guess to
having that big fandom behind it but
that's fascinating that of all the
fandoms that and or's not here yeah
Lord of the Rings too that's what I feel
like I feel like the vote got split yes
in the same way that you'll see a
presidential race and it sort of
fractures a party and it hurts that
party overall because you had some
people vote for and or maybe some people
were like no I'm more of an Obi-Wan
person or Mandalorian whatever the
season Sue might have been this year
book of Boba Fett okay so who's Bernie
who's Elizabeth I mean it's break it
down I mean this is the kicker but
that's the thing Within These fandoms
these very big fandoms they're now
gearing content very specifically like
you can look at a show like Obi-Wan and
be like okay this is for the you know
you know you know 70s Skywalker folks
and you look at Andor it's like these
for the folks that maybe just only
watched the animated shows and have no
attachment to the earlier years and they
just really want to see new exciting
stories and so yeah I could totally see
somebody who loved animal door is a Star
Wars fan who would never even consider
voting for like book a Boba Fett yeah
but you would think that one of them
would have edged through here Fair
especially those Andor fans I feel like
they are die hard I like dandora but
aren't they quiet I feel like Andor is
still the show that could like it's a
show that's definitely gaining a
popularity and the Emmys are helping but
it is not like this show has been like
they're not live episodes now for what
two months it's been off of live
episodes something like that and they're
just now getting people to talk about it
post um the nominations that it just got
yeah I just think Anders the more adult
Star Wars where it's not as kid-friendly
it's not as cuddly and so Andor is kind
of the same thing as the bear where it's
like you want to rush out and recommend
it to everybody but actually know who
you're talking to yeah wait I'm not
throwing my my niece and my nephews into
Andor just yet I might show them Obi One
there's some scary parts but like and or
you're gonna have to I want you to
understand the the geopolitical things
about Earth before we get to the galaxy
far far away but a lot of wonderful TV
as there is every year and Roxy's
drivers our special guest today she saw
literally all of it so before we wrap
things up here in our movie slash TV
talk we're talking about Awards and it's
the season of giving Jacqueline your
take on the Oscar nominations that came
out if you're able to frame it into just
a more concise one or two pieces of rye
bread take because I know there's so
many people that have so many feelings
pro and con about the nominations that
we got whether it's best picture one of
the acting categories yeah and then Roxy
I love your take as well anything stood
out to you about the Oscar nominations
like what was sort of the biggest
takeaway for you okay I'm gonna give you
my favorite nomination
um of the day because there were a ton
of nominations that a lot of people like
talked about uh but my favorite
nomination of the day is actually Ryan
Johnson getting a second Oscar
nomination best original screenplay for
Glass Onion the reason why I say this is
because speaking of Star Wars fans after
the Last Jedi if you talk to her like
you know he lost that Triple Star Wars
series
um it was before he did knives out I
mean if you talk about somebody at that
point in his career just looking on the
internet you would definitely think one
way or the other and since then he's
directed and stars in Two
oscar-nominated screenplays that earn a
ton of money although one of them is a
streaming title and the other one was in
the box office and he does this new show
with Natasha Leone which is dope Poker
Face I watched the first two episodes so
good so good and I like literally kind
of want to give a thing yeah she's only
skill yeah
um I kind of want to thank them because
I'm really excited to sort of see what
he is going to be able to do uh with
this new freedom because he's going to
be able to just create whatever stories
he wants to create and it kind of shows
that it doesn't matter the medium it
doesn't matter whether it's Star Wars or
a detective story or this really like
a-lister action film because he this guy
did Looper I'm getting more excited for
where these directors are going to go
now that they've become more established
it's an aspiring story for anybody who
and it's also a good lesson for anybody
who wants to write something original is
get off your phone and get onto your
laptop or whatever you don't use Wi-Fi
at the coffee shop because he basically
got so crushed for The Last Jedi
unjustly in my opinion that he took the
entire summer off of social media I'm
just going to write this fun murder
mystery and that's how he got knives out
and that's how we have this franchise
um the Oscar nominations were released I
guess as of this recording last week
Roxy Stark did you have a huge takeaway
that was either oh I'm glad this movie
guy recognition or this person or was
there a snub that you're just like what
what are we doing here yeah Marcel
should have been nominated in best
picture for short I don't know why I
smile because it's worth it
it's getting worse it's getting worse no
I think that the obviously a lot of
people were really surprised about Viola
Davis and Andrew Riceboro and the and
who was nominated and who was not I was
shocked that James Cameron was not
nominated I feel like you spent 10 years
on something and the movie gets
nominated and you are the movie he's the
whole movie I mean he's top middle and
end he not only is he this movie he's
the next 10 years of these movies so
it's not even that I thought that he
that the movie should be nominated or
shouldn't it's just if you're going to
nominate the movie and not nominate him
that was It was kind of strange I think
I don't know this for sure but just
again I know more people in that Branch
than I have previously and like just
based on what I would think it's the
same thing that happened with Lord of
the Rings when that came out you don't
honor him on the first Endeavor it's
kind of the Achilles heel in the sense
that he said he's making three they're
gonna wait yeah they're gonna win it
becomes that lifetime achievement awards
it's the same reason why Denny didn't
get it on Dune part one it it's going to
be the compilation between the two and
that's always the way they think about
it and I don't know why that is but it
is when they know that there's more
multiple Parts even if the first one is
brilliant you kind of have to stick the
ending because they don't want to give
best picture to something that's the
start or like best directed or something
that's the start of something awful yeah
I don't think he should have won but a
nomination it's also weird we all know
how life works you don't know what's
going to happen
disagree with you we'll nominate you
hope it works out I don't disagree with
you girl but historically like you can
see it it happened with the Lord of the
Rings with all of the nominations yeah I
mean like it literally they take it
seriously towards the end and you know
Avatar's still getting some run and best
picture as your top gun Maverick I'm not
going to be one of these folks that
thinks top gun Maverick deserved a
denomination in every category although
it's a great movie so I'm not going to
cry about the cinematography there's a
lot of Welsh beautifully looking movies
in 2022. what I will say is I posted
something that made the rounds on social
media the morning of the Oscars and I'll
reiterated here if you're not going to
nominate jackass forever for best
picture let jackass forever the entire
cast hosts the Oscars you want ratings
you want more eyeballs on the ceremony
has to read throughout the three hour of
your ratings this year if that were to
happen do you think there's any
possibility no no but they could show up
they should they could show up they
could do a skit I could totally see them
having a skit by the way that was my
favorite movie of 2022 was jackass it
was my number one without question not
just because of like the movie itself
which I think is brilliant like these
are men who made their entire career off
of getting hit in the nuts and being
inappropriate and they still found found
a way to be inclusive and like Turn the
Page and become like a modern day thing
and somehow I look at them getting hit
in the nuts and think to myself wow
you're really doing it you know what I
mean it is impressive like and so the
fact that I love the um the idea of what
Jackass did in the sense that they got
older and they patched the torch and
they still managed to elevate it but
also it was just an incredible viewing
situation because it didn't matter if it
was like Gen X like little kids who like
maybe only know Stevo from his podcast
to like people like myself who remember
guys like being jackasses in their
backyard all in a communal setting
Living For The Moment don't try it at
home kids but that entire film franchise
I believe every movie in jackass in the
lineage is fresh on the Tomato Meter and
so there's a lot of freshness there but
it's hard to it's hard to argue with the
fan favorites for both movies of 2022
the golden tomato goes to RR and for TV
series stranger things season four maybe
a bogey the last hole big rebound birdie
there for stranger things so we
transitioned to a thank you and a good
night here Roxy Strayer it is always a
delight having you in studio we kind of
just did the World Girls hat trick
because we had stuff to Brown last week
we had Doreen Ariano on talking about
movies and now you're here blessing us
with both movie and TV talk we hinted
that you already seen some poker face
which we also agree that we like and The
Last of Us what's the streaming show do
you think everybody needs to catch on to
that we could see when a golden tomato
this coming year
Paul T Goldman have you guys heard of
this show this is wild if you it's but
the director worked on Nathan for you
and Borat so it's kind of mixing reality
with scripted it is a bell I I want to
say it's about a con artist I won't
explain any more than that this show is
wild and people aren't talking about it
unless you watch 50 episodes of TV
really really up girl yeah you can
follow her on all social media at
roxystar and check out all the Endeavors
that the world girls do they don't quite
get into jackass territory but they've
been known to try some physical uh shall
we say hurdles from time to time we eat
bugs and stuff we're a little jacket we
eat bugs and stuff oh God I want that to
be mine well one of them failed at uh
who faded it uh two of us two of them
fainted at the Magic Mountain yeah what
making a movie it was hot that day we we
eat bugs and stuff I'm sorry like that
is wax we bugs we do I don't think that
is like awesome like legitimately
nothing like we're the World Girls We
bugs and stuff like make it on a shirt
put it on a t-shirt they do a counter
every year next year's counter probably
gonna be them eating a different sort of
exotic insect honestly grasshoppers not
bad it's kind of delicious chocolate
done Cricket no maybe you can get
through it don't be a wimp about it that
is Roxy stryer give hero and all of her
cool things that she's doing whether
it's on TV online radio all that good
stuff in between and check out the World
Girls podcast out of water where
they talk about some more serious issues
she's just doing a lot of great stuff
and it's an honor to call her a friend
and a parking mate downstairs in P3 we
are Rotten Tomatoes is wrong make sure
you email us let us know what movies and
TV shows you want us to cover on an
upcoming episode RT is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com that's also where you
go is our website rottentomatoes.com for
all the golden tomato stuff Jacqueline
Coley we like when the kids reviews
describe whatever your platform of
choice encourages you to do go ahead and
do that for your friends here at Rotten
Tomatoes it's wrong next week we're
getting back into a single movie that
some people feel has been unjustly
maligned on the Tomato Meter what are we
talking about breaking out of the cell
about the one woman the one woman Army
herself listen we're gonna talk JLo and
it's not going to be about benefer but
it's not going to be far from that time
it's not going to be not not about
benefits
giant snake movie too some Selena should
be a whole lot of JLo talk with the cell
that is Jacqueline Cole you can find her
at that Jacqueline I am at Mark Ellis
live upcoming tour dates at
markellis.live for the whole team here
at Rotten Tomatoes thanks for tuning in
to Rotten Tomatoes is wrong and we'll
see you next week
[Music]
thank you